welcome everybody um i want to start
today with something that's really
interesting but not super surprising
which is that the united states
coronavirus vaccination map
looks just like the 2020 presidential
election results map if you want to
predict which states voted for trump
look at the states
that aren't really getting vaccinated at
the higher rates in the country if you
want to predict which states are getting
vaccinated
look at the list of states where joe
biden got more of a share of the vote
relative to donald trump and it's
actually incredible
how accurately this can predict
vaccination
if you look at the top 25 states
in terms of what portion of the
population has been vaccinated
joe biden won 21 of those 25 states in
the 2020 election
when you look at the bottom 25 states
in terms of vaccination rate donald
trump won
21 of those 25 states including 16
of the worst 17 states when it comes to
vaccination
the correlation between vaccination rate
and the 2020 election outcome by state
has strengthened over time and that's
another
important thing to consider we've talked
about how anti-vaccine sentiment has
declined over time
even among republicans like for example
last month 43
of republicans didn't want the vaccine
this month
only 41 of republicans don't want the
vaccine even within that
if you are a republican in a blue state
you are far more likely to want a
vaccine
than if you are a republican in a red
state now in addition to this there's a
big
urban rural divide when it comes to
vaccination
just like there's an urban rural divide
in trump versus biden
but let's put some visuals to this for
people who are
watching us today check out some of
these images from aca signups.net
this is a chart of vaccination rate
versus
trump support at the state level and you
see that the numbers are arranged along
a diagonal line
to the right it is a higher trump vote
and you see a
lower vaccination rate it's just a
perfect plot
to the left is a higher biden vote and
you see much
higher vaccination rates now you could
say hold on a second david hold on sir
states vary in population you have
really big blue states and you have some
really small red states so if you just
look at states that
could be deceptive it might not really
give us an accurate picture of this
the second image here from aca
signups.net
is county by county and similarly
although you have more
outliers like there are some blue
counties
where very few people want to get
vaccinated i would love to know where
those are
but it's basically the same patter
pattern higher trump vote
lower vaccination higher biden vote
higher vaccination and it only requires
thinking back to the last what 15 16
months to understand what's going on
here
if you have been told for a year by your
fearless leader
this isn't serious this is like the flu
15 cases will soon be zero we don't need
masks we don't need to close we
need kids in schools you might get the
sense
that you don't really need a vaccine and
thus you aren't going to go and get
yourself one trump said it would be gone
in april
last april of eight not one month ago 13
months
ago why would you need a vaccine for
that
but the real tragedy here is that
politicizing the tax rate okay you know
politicizing debt and deficit that's one
thing
if something that is simply a public
health
measure that saves lives like a
vaccination
that is 90 plus percent effective if
that can fall into the same political
traps the same political games
then quite literally anything can and
that's a horrifying reality to have to
accept
there are trumpists now posting to
social media
like a badge of honor that they have not
and they will not get vaccinated and the
government's not going to tread on them
and force them to get vaccinated well
yeah no the government's not going to
force you to do it of course we know
that
uh but they are wearing this lack of
vaccination as a badge of honor now so
at the end of the day
trump's politicization of the pandemic
continues trump's gone but it will
continue to cause deaths american deaths
due to this anti-vaccine sentiment and
increasingly because of this partisan
split
trump's mishandling and propagandizing
around the pandemic
will lead to more republican deaths than
democratic deaths
as we have increasingly i mean there are
blue states that are at 70
vaccinated already that's essentially
herd immunity cases are going
to zero almost statistically um
not literally zero statistical zero
where you get down to a number that
you know the r the the rate of
reproduction is extremely low
um this is an incredible situation
because it is going to take on an
incredible partisan divide as we go
forward with
red state and republican clusters of the
virus
it's a horrible thing and i don't care
what your partisan identification is
i don't want anybody to die i don't want
anybody to get sick and we are very
quickly seeing an incredible
red blue divide happening when it comes
to vaccination
one of our sponsors today is covid
rescue
fund covet rescue fund is helping small
business owners
who have lost their businesses during
covid
there are over 100 000 small businesses
that have had to close their doors since
the pandemic began
there are many organizations out there
helping businesses who are still open
to stay afloat but covet rescue fund is
one of the few organizations working to
help businesses
reopen who have had to close covet
rescue fund
crowdsources funds to provide grants up
to one hundred thousand dollars
for these owners to create new
businesses
i would implore anyone in my audience to
help covid rescue fund in their mission
by donating at covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses as we can
the link is right underneath this video